foreign
Jessica's with us in Madison Wisconsin
high Jessica welcome to the Ramsey Show
hi thanks for having me on great how can
we help
um so my question is I had received some
money when my dad passed away we used
that money to pay off vehicles and use
it as a down payment on our house and
all we had for debt then was a mortgage
since then we bought a tractor and built
a barn
we were told to just let the money ride
in the market we were never going to
touch it that was that was retirement
money as I've been listening to your
show the last couple weeks I'm wondering
if that was the best advice we were
given and if we should pull the money
from you know the stocks and pay off our
debt and then yeah and then you need to
quit buying crap you can't afford like
Barns and tractors
it's stuff needed for our mobile
all right
you're buying stuff you can't afford
okay you know how I know you did that
you borrowed on it instead of paying for
it
if it was such a dadgum good investment
you would have already used Eddie's
stock money on that
hello
yep I'm I'm here yeah my my question is
do we pull the money from the the stocks
and no you don't unless you're going to
quit borrowing money and on the next
thing that you'd rationalize and justify
but if your stop rationalizing and
justifying your purchases on debt
because you're going to eventually run
out of this if you keep this Behavior
pattern going
but if you stop the behavior pattern and
say I'm never borrowing again we're
going to pay cash for everything we do
from this point forward then yes we did
this but the last time you paid off all
your debts what'd you do the next time
thing that came up you went back in debt
and so if I tell you to pay off this
debt next thing that comes up you're
going to go back in debt I don't want
that for you that's not a that's not a
method to Prosperity that's a method to
bankruptcy
and so you've got to put your you know
you gotta spit shaking uh pinky swear
with your husband we we're not borrowing
money anymore if you're going to do that
then yeah I'll take the money out and
pay off the debt but otherwise you're
destined to live a life of put and take
we're gonna pay it off then we're gonna
go back in debt we're gonna pay it off
and we're gonna go back in debt and
eventually we don't need money to pay it
off
eventually you run out of the nest egg
doing that so you've got to break this
pattern and you were very clear we used
some of the money cleared off all the
debt wait how did we celebrate we bought
a tractor in a barn and went back in
debt you've got to break that cycle you
can't do that again and again and again
there's an end to it and the end ain't
pretty
so that's what I want for you
um and there's no rationalization no
justification you got to be done you'll
be done you gotta decide we're done you
know it's an investment it's always an
investment everybody says everything's
an investment that they want to buy but
most things aren't yeah and this is a
key point about behaviors aren't
Investments or the barn so what happens
is when you feel the need to have
something you have to go okay what's the
least amount of thing that I need to do
what I want to do could we have done a
shed that we could have paid cash for
what's Behind These purchases not
prospective opportunities I'm going to
need this Barn one day if we don't need
the bar now then we don't need to buy
the bar now and I think that's where
people have got to start looking at this
and going what do I really need do I
need a big tractor do I need an old used
tractor that'll do the job and that's
what people have to do or else you
justify debt almost every one of us
buy a different thing when we buy it
with debt than if we had bought it with
cash I agree with that 100 almost every
one of us yeah and you buy a bigger
badder cooler that's correct crazier
yeah nuttier yeah Dumber right thing you
got to find a way because it doesn't
feel like it's real money when it's the
bank's money that's absolutely right and
that's the that's the Trap of this it's
a it's a siren song yeah and it you know
you'll crash this puppy on the rocks and
that's what the sirens do to you